well that's Wales as thoughts turn
towards next year's Welsh Assembly
elections the leader of plight camry has
called on labour voters to give her
party another look and Leanne wood has
got the backing of the Scottish First
Minister Nicola Sturgeon who was her
warmer back to the party's conference
last week and as you can see now it
joins me now from South Wales in a very
good morning to you so is that calling
in Nicola Sturgeon and admission that to
you and your party don't quite have the
the Stardust of the SNP yet well we work
very closely as parties we've been
sister parties for many many years and
of course we are at different parties
represent in different countries but I
think we're on the same journey and I
think now the plight Camry is in the
place where the SNP was ahead of the
year 2007 breakthrough in Scotland when
they formed a minority government we've
got our elections to our National
Assembly next year and my party is in
great shape to contest those elections
and offer the people of Wales a real
alternative government to labour who
we've had in power for 17 years and
broken rule since devolution was born
it's interesting what you say about the
parallels between yourselves on the SNP
in 2007 so can I extend that and say
then you're 7 years away from risking a
referendum on independence well that is
going to be a matter decided by people
here in Wales of course and there when
the appetite for more autonomy grows
then played Camry is ready to take that
journey with people but our priorities
now are public services we've got
chronic problems in our health service
there are major problems with our
economy and challenges faced in our
education system as well and what people
tell us is that they want solutions to
those problems and we've spent quite a
bit of time trying to find those
solutions and we'll be putting those
forward in our programme of government
ahead of that election next May and I
very much hope that people will like
what they see and vote for it ok I mean
but it is very much the SNP template I
mean just on the narrow issue of a
firend immed you seriously think there
might be one in Wales in your political
lifetime
well yes III think there could well be I
mean at the end of the day it's a matter
for people to decide and we've got many
problems here in Wales and we don't have
a constitutional settlement through our
National Assembly to be able to solve
some of those problems so more autonomy
is needed greater powers are needed for
our National Assembly but we're a
different country to Scotland our
devolution journey started from a
different place in 1997 when we voted
for our referendum for example in
Scotland the criminal justice system the
education system was already devolved
they had a banking and finance sector
that we didn't have in Wales so we've
had a build from scratch here so our
journey has been slower but there's no
doubt there's nothing inferior about
Wales that means that we can't be a
success that we can't stand on our own
two feet but what we're lacking is
leadership and a government that has the
will and a plan to turn around our
fortunes but there are no problems that
we have in ways that can't be fixed with
political determination but that's a
attack on the leadership you have in
Wales on the Labour Party in Wales is of
course joined you joined in that by
conservatives in Wales I've heard it and
indeed conservatives nationally I've
heard an awful lot of what you've said
and have said in the past about the way
the health service in Wales is being run
I've heard an awful lot of that said by
conservatives well I guess what we're
doing is reflecting public opinion I've
spent quite a lot of time and my shadow
cabinet team as well going up and down
the country addressing people in town
hall meetings and on their doorsteps and
it's overwhelmingly the issue that comes
back to us as the the main priority of
people is health so I guess we're just
reflecting that the difference between
plate Kamri and the Tories on this is
that the Tories are very good at
describing the problem and shouting a
lot about it but what we've done is come
up with solutions to those problems so
for example we have a plan to train and
recruit 2,000 extra
does to integrate health and social care
to provide free social care for people
with wood over 65 and with dementia and
so we put a package together of
solutions to try to address the problems
that people have told us they feel at a
priority just the specifics this so
Wales bill that you've called it
insulting haven't you know just explain
to people why you feel you know reading
through it it seems to me that it's
offering Wales
quite a lot more devolution more power
as you say it is insulting and and risk
sending powers back to London well the
problem with the bill as it stands is
that it is meant to call provide
clarification and it risks causing more
confusion and it risks taken some power
back from Cardiff to London and that's
very much something we're opposed to
there could be a simple way of dealing
with this by creating a Welsh legal
jurisdiction that's something that the
Tories don't want to do it's very much
something we are pushing for and with
that of course over time the devolution
of the criminal justice system policing
probation courts as well but what we
have in the Wales bill is a lowest
common denominator approach a group of
politicians sat around a table and all
effectively had a veto on which powers
could be devolved and what we've been
presented with is something very very
weak indeed and yes it is insulting when
our national institution on our
Constitution needs a revamp that this
pathetic bill has come forward so it's
not too late to strengthen it and my MPs
will be working hard to make sure that
it
the amendments go down and I very much
hope that other opposition parties will
support plate Kamri in that but what
happens at the at the end of this
process remains to be seen and we're
great to talk to the leader of pride
Kamri there in the abdominal or on that
thank you very much